حكيمه
الى اشرف اشرف حكيمي
الطائر
الظهير المتكامل سرعه قوه تسديد المواصلات
اهداف نجم اسود الاطلس اشرف حكيمي مسيره
كرويه مميزه بدات من الملكيه الاسبانيه ثم
الى بروسيا دورتموند قبل ان يعود الى ريال
مدريد لينطلق الى انتر ميلان واخيرا الى
عملاق باريس
مسيره لم تكن تتوقعها اسرته البسيطه التي
هاجرت من المغرب الى اسبانيا قبل ولادته
والده كان بائعا متجلا بينما عملت والدته
في المنازل للوفاء لمتطلبات المعيشه
مدريد وينو باور رينجرز
ليلتحق باكاديميته لعبني مختلف فرق
الناشئين حتى ضمه الاسطوره زين الدين
زيدان للفريق الاول فانقلبت حياته الفتى
واسرته وانطلقا من اكاديميه الملكيه
الاسبانيه ليجوبا القاره العجوز تاركا لدى
كبار انديتها ويكون اولا مغربي يتوج بدوري
ابطال اوروبا وثاني عربي بعد الجزائري
رابح ماجر
ان شاء الله
منتخب المغرب الذي فضل عليه منتخب اسبانيا
في الوصول لكاس العالم 2018 ومونديال قطر
2022 حيث ينظرون الاسود تحديا جديدا
يطمحون فيه الى تجاوز دور المجموعات
والذهاب بعيدا لادوار الاقصائيه فهل
يفعلها حكيم ورفاقه
[تصفيق]